this is Startalk and I'm your host Neil
deGrasse Tyson your personal
astrophysicist and today's edition of
Startalk is cosmic queries whatever the
hell came off the internet that's what
we're doing today and my co-host a hello
the first time we're doing this together
and you got a whole comedy background
right with the with the Harvard Lampoon
I was at Harvard I did not do the lamp
we didn't do the when I was there so
they didn't take me what's that how that
works the year that they don't take you
they become jerks oh okay
so we're getting the Lampoon rejects
you've reached that low point of low
point actually my dad was on the Lampoon
and I didn't want to join for that you
have a comedic dad hey what is a dad
joke of a comedic dad they're worse they
better or they're worse there's so much
worse there's so much I get accused of
dad joke I just say something I think is
kind of funny I'm on Twitter thanks dad
[Laughter]
I'm thinking I'm being clever but I'm
just being a dad at least you have jokes
there's no mom Joe territory that's true
yeah what's that about
no just saying standards here because
the weight of the world is on the
shoulders of moms not a joking matter
so as usual these questions are
collected from our internet fan base
from Instagram Twitter and Facebook very
cool yeah it's totally legit
and I don't know if you were better at
pronouncing people's names then Chuck
nice we will decide that in this episode
yeah we'll see about I'm just gonna say
it loudly and confidently and I think
it'll be convincing even if it's wrong
it's confident exactly I mean they don't
know they're not gonna bust in the door
but no one else will know you mean
they'll know no one else will know so
what's the first question
all right so the first one actually has
a guide to pronouncing the name it comes
from
yaniv costs our patreon patreon and his
name he says well get their questions
answered first oh yeah
no yeah
by this right this class citizen that's
yeah
blessed be his name yaniv is pronounced
like Yaniv and it rhymes with achieve
that's what it says on the knees good
look he addresses it to Chuck which I'm
gonna take as a personal so my question
to dr. Tyson are we near the center of
the universe and as a personal follow-up
is that Center as I've lawns long
suspected me oh yeah that's your
follow-up or the center I made it better
Sarah you are the center of your own
universe alright that's it interviews
over and but you're not the center of
anyone else's universe nor the universe
itself well yeah the universe has no
center and just because you can put the
noun in verbs together to make a
sentence that sounds like it should have
an answer where is the center of the
universe are we there does not require
that it has an answer for example here's
a question that you know not to ask
where is the center of Earth's surface
how much you're flat earther and think
we have a disk which would have a center
we all know you're a big fan big fan but
this spherical earth you know you know
to not even ask that yeah you know this
so it turns out the universe has no
center because everything in this
universe was at the same place at the
same time and we call that the Big Bang
so it kind of had a center but it's not
accessible today you have to go
backwards 13.8 billion years and the
whole universe was at its own center in
that moment it's interested a lot of the
questions actually were kind of off this
topic and somebody even said explicitly
I can't imagine the universe as anything
but a sphere it seems almost innate that
we think of it as like a physical space
with the center yeah so but that's
that's fine I'm just saying it one way
to to visualize this is to take away one
of the dimensions because our brains are
too feeble and to imagine four
dimensions or five dimensions is take
away dimension and put the whole
universe on this surface of a balloon
draw a little spiral galaxies
if you inflate the balloon all the
galaxies get farther away from all other
and if you were on a galaxy sale we at
the center know where is the center are
you at the center nobody gets to say
they're at the center you know why
because the center is not on that
surface the center is when the balloon
was smaller when the blue was
infinitesimally 13.8 billion years ago
and when that happened everybody was at
the center so I was at the center then
okay thanks allow me to remind you that
the the opening quote of my current book
astrophysics for people in a hurry which
is really cheap plug for that book but I
have to save it yeah I've just agreed
that a si si si si - si plus I open it
with just how to set you straight and
say the universe is under no obligation
to make sense to you yeah I remember
that I love that introduction that
that's all it is and that's I put it in
that book printed for the first time
yeah no that was that was a fantastic
introduction because it was touching on
a feeling you didn't realize you had mmm
oh I like those yeah absolutely a really
tugged at that emotion okay moving on to
our next question this one it comes from
user named Ollie me amcd 98 on instagram
who says if all galaxies in the universe
are expanding away from us then what is
the cause for the Andromeda galaxy being
on a collision course with our own
excellent question
beautiful that's beautiful so let's go
back to our rubber sheet analogy and a
moment ago is the surface of a balloon
just put us all on a rubber sheet and
you have this rubber sheet that's
expanding so I you're my neighbor galaxy
and you're my closest galaxy you let's
say you move away from me at one inch
per second let's say you'll look to your
neighbor galaxy and you'll see it move
away from you at one inch per second
mm-hmm it will see its neighbor galaxy
move away from it at one inch per second
I will see your neighbor galaxy move
away from me at two inches per second I
will see that galaxy's neighbor galaxy
move away at three inches per second so
the farther away you are from any
point of observation the faster is the
measured expansion mm-hmm because
everything is expanding uniformly and it
just adds up I thought everything was
expenses except that's a whole that's
another level on top of this it's
overtime it's on top of this that's
happening okay but that's we that will
neither we don't need to reference that
now to get to answer his question I see
a basic expanding universe we are
expanding mm-hmm
so so in other words if you invoke that
then I would see it so as you go back in
time the you you would see that the the
expansion was greater okay as the time
had moved on because as you look out in
the universe you were looking back in
time right that's right so you see
things not as they are but as they once
were beautiful it was an Italian movie
called la correspondence la correspond
ends and it starred Jeremy Irons okay it
was a love story fan takes me to is a
bit I'm a big fan of his I was a love
story and he played an astrophysicist
and he had one do you like Daddy
terminal disease had to go abroad his
love interest did not know he was ill
and he actually died but he had
preloaded letters to arrive to her long
after he died so that his spirit his
energy would still be alive in her heart
and this was analogized to star light a
star may have died mm-hmm but it's light
continuing to travel through space
remind you of its continued existence
long after it is gone correspondence yes
beautiful so the key to immortality is
just send a bunch of mail there so the
post office when they're delayed in
their mail they're just like we want to
extend your legacy yes yes because
they're doing on purpose exactly you
know the question was asking about
reference points of expansion but I feel
like I
graduating from college see my own
reference point as expanding like I am
expanding away from myself
oh so fat so everything is expanding hmm
well so you expand from what you once
were yes provided you view college
commencement mm-hmm as the beginning of
learning rather than the end that's true
I mean isn't the the last the graduation
speeches are called commencement which
means beginning the whole celebration is
it commencement right I know there's a
commencement speech it's intended to
mean beginning right and you would know
there's a gate at Harvard where if you
enter the Harvard Yard what through that
game as an undergraduate you were there
yeah but the gate says enter to grow in
wisdom yes have you read the other side
of that gate leave to get so it says
exit to serve better the country and the
kind mm-hmm
so yeah you exit and now you grow I
always found it ironic though that it is
there's a huge superstition about that
gate which is if you go through it
before you graduate that you won't ever
get to graduate which to me feels like a
very ignorant superstition to have about
a gate that superstition for one of the
highest incidences behold moving forth
yeah yeah no I was not into superstition
yeah but it still pervades our
superstitions stuporous it I like that
getting back to your fellows question so
the nearby galaxies will be receding
from you slower than all other galaxies
that are farther away mm-hmm fact number
one fact number two all galaxies have
movement relative to one another
mm-hmm okay and it turns out that the
movement of Andromeda at its distance
from us is greater than the expansion of
the universe between us
oh so it's coming towards us so it can
overcome the expansion of the universe
being so close to us if the Andromeda
galaxy we're at any farther distance the
expansion of the universe would override
it hmm so generally you have nearby
galaxies colliding towards one
their gravity overcomes the expansion of
the universe this is why how you have
colliding galaxies at all yeah it was a
great question it is a matter of what is
the distance to the object it is
interesting because I I I was
researching the collision course with
the Andromeda galaxy in our own and I it
said the prediction was four billion
years yeah I think it's a little longer
than that but because that's sooner than
the Sun is like set to collapse yes so
it's a it's a it's a technique it's a
technicality
the systems are huge hmm the Andromeda
galaxy and the Milky Way yeah they're
huge so you have to ask when you're
going to say is the moment that they
start colliding right what is that
moment and so is it when the outer
reaches the suburbs hit one another when
their nuclei hit one another or when
they settle down into one giant mass
yeah double the number star is that the
two separate systems had to begin with
and so if you add all that up its
hundreds of millions of years for the
system to settle into a new galaxy so
it's not accurate to think of it as a
single moment yeah actually nASA has a
really great animation of what that
looks like and it's it's um it's sort of
like going out and coming back in yeah
it's a train wreck yeah and so what
happens they overshoot one another yeah
and get and stars are cast hither and
yon and then they come back and it's a
mess and it takes a long time for all
that to settle out again the the
scientific word for that is to relax
yeah relaxed systems are not chaotic
they're actually rather rather organized
and two colliding spiral galaxies
that'll be a while two before that
settles out so you could easily say it
will begin as early as five billion
years but all the action yeah gonna
happen later okay so you're more patient
all right all right so moving on to our
next question
and though I'm very excited about this
one this one come from this one comes
from Lukas lumps on Instagram could it
be possible to not Lance um you know I
just said it confidently I committed to
long because it's fancy okay because
it's a brittle Lukas long it's Lukas
lawns and then a
official so I pronounced it officially
Oh I mean it's officially recognized on
Instagram could it be possible that a
deja vu is a phenomenon where two
different identical timelines in two
different identical universes cross
paths and create some sort of mental
link between me and my timeline and me
in the alternate timeline yes Wow okay
III don't think we fully understand deja
vu yeah it was a George Carlin who said
sometimes I go into a place and I'm
certain I've never been there before
that's a vuja de I think it was George
Carlin like that yeah so I actually I
forgive me for not knowing what the
literal translation of deja vu is yeah
it means already seen already syncs with
the roux is the scene Dasia manage of
you so so I I don't have a problem with
that theory
I don't hypothesis there's the theory of
gravity relativity quantum theory and
Freddie's theory right so I I think
there's more to learn from that I think
our brains are more complex yeah no
we've come to recognize how complex they
actually are but just because something
happens in your brain doesn't mean it is
the measure of an objective reality and
most of human experiences do not sorry
most of human curious brain phenomena
does not take root in objective reality
yeah I have very low confidence that
this idea will bear fruit yeah deja vu
is intersecting parallel universes
simply because your brain I could put
you in a room put throw some simple
drugs into you and you'll hallucinate
look at what happens to your brain with
the tiniest of chemical disruption
mm-hmm
you don't have a more acute sense of
reality you have a
a lesser sense of reality yeah melody is
measured by recording devices in the
room that your happen to be sitting no I
saw a green clown and of it yep yep yep
have you heard of a husband's poem about
a penknife no he says I need but stick
this in my heart and down will follow
the sky and earth and heaven shall
depart and all of you will die and it's
about how he thinks if he kills himself
that the rest of the world will depart
because that's what it feels like I
figured out that that's what the poem
did you really think that poem needed
explanation see you a poem is this
phenomenon where that was not one of the
obscure poems but no I midnight ride of
Paul Revere this poem is about a man
named Paul Revere rode a horse at
midnight did some poems thankfully don't
need full it was for the the point is
yes we've read a lot of things we see a
lot of things and we don't retain active
knowledge that they sit in our memories
mm-hmm
we could have had things described to us
and then we made a picture of what was
described you don't have deja vu every
place you go into and you don't even
have it every day
mm-hmm once a week once a month times a
year so of all the places you've been in
you surely is gonna be one that matches
up with some book you read movie you saw
I had deja vu we were I forgot where I
was over in Louisiana somewhere in the
south and I was with in some conference
and we drove by a cemetery
not a big one kind of a church unity
between a cemetery Anna na na a
graveyard there spelled differently yes
a difference no you really don't know
I'm all proud of it cuz I only learned
it like a week ago
okay okay so a graveyard is attached to
a church oh okay cemeteries wherever the
hell it is hmm and since the yard
it's the yard of the church yeah yeah so
I passed this cemetery might have been a
graveyard I didn't remember if there was
a church near and I said it was kind of
a twilight yeah
I've seen this before but I know I'd
never been on that so I had a deja vu
mm-hmm and then the the bus driver said
and we just passed the cemetery that was
the backdrop in Michael Jackson's the
Thriller you know the weirdest thing is
we've had this conversation before Neil
we got to take a quick break before we
come back to cosmic queries Oguri
edition on Startalk we're back on
Startalk yes it is i how am i doing so
far people observing because Chuck isn't
or normally like sitting right there and
people and the queries people are
phonetically spelling their name to help
Chuck along yeah and you're up there
reading the names for I'm doing my best
I'm doing my best impression of chat
it's very subtle there you go Oh
collected from the Internet just grab
bagg happy to feel if I don't know the
answer I'll just tell you okay yes
loudly and confidently all right this
one's actually my favorite question
really yeah I'm just gonna throw it out
there
from Brandon Bagley on Facebook what
would be a more accurate name for the
Big Bang there is no more accurate name
oh the Big Bang geez Wow and what many
people don't know is that there's a
great astrophysicist sir Fred Hoyle who
was not a fan of the Big Bang back when
there was enough slop in the data mhm
to not have to vote strongly one way or
another he was convinced that the
universe was was in a steady state
mm-hmm he knew the universe was
expanding so how do you have an
expanding universe that's also in a
steady state you would have the universe
spontaneously create atoms out of the
vacuum and then they would make new
galaxies and they would mix in with the
old galaxies so statistically the
universe's looks the same forever
he's been expanding forever
and it gets rid of the origins problem
then the idea of a big bang arose hmm
this was consistent with Einstein's
general theory of relativity and then
George Lemaitre who was a Belgian priest
and mathematician he figured out if you
turn the equations backwards all the
universe would have been in one place at
one time then is a guy named George
gamma who calculated what that should
look like and there'd be a residue left
over from this moment and it would be
this background in microwaves and so all
this got laid out and Fred Hoyle wasn't
having any of it and he pejoratively
referenced this idea as the Big Bang he
was making fun of it right but it's
stuck it's stuck stuck and we are living
it that's like when you get a nickname
to stick like you just you know you sort
of appropriate it yep yep then they
can't use it against you yeah exactly
right and so so there was the thought
that there was enough gravity to halt
the expansion and have it repeat that
had philosophical attraction to people
because it meant the universe didn't
have to have a beginning in total we're
just on a cycle who knows what cycle
maybe we've been going on forever I
rinse this compress that's right this
this this this concept of a beginning
somehow people people I don't really
want it or they really don't want it
Yeah right there's there's a bifurcation
of attitude towards it that's like a
Rorschach test if this people want to
see is you know my wife told me before
she was my wife but she has a degree in
physics it's somehow still managed to be
your wife after this no no she said she
wondered whether there was a split
between men and women about this steady
state universe and the in a cyclic
universe men don't have the cycles right
yeah so just just what is your
philosophical leaning towards an idea
and if it that philosophy emanates from
the life that you lead and
and resonate with you could have this
split between men and women and she
hypothesized that oh then guys say like
oaths so the universe is like super big
like it's like trust me uh ya know Fred
well I actually like look he wanted the
steady universe not exactly
cyclic universe you wanted to go steady
go steady very good this is a pretty
good quote about it he says that words
like harpoons stick and are hard to pull
out mm-hmm I actually think that an
answer to bridge for a whaler part time
it was that he dabbled in whaling he was
a yes Fred Hoyle
oh you make himself nobody and whaling
I'm glad that I could get you on that
though yeah I haul whales as a hobby
aside part time whale so so once he he
he said it pejoratively it's stuck then
he had no he had nothing on us at that
point and then there were observation
confirming the prediction nobel prize
was given he went to his grave pretty
much still a denier the Big Bang so in a
so it getting back to my point if the
question was what better word would I
have term what I have for it there are
people who if the universe would wreak
elapsed and then start as a bang again
they call that the Big Crunch I don't
know why they wanted to say crunch if
you look up that phrase it's it's there
because gas clouds and stars they don't
go crunch right potato chips crunch
crunchy things crunch the universe is
not crunchy yeah so I just thought it
was not the Big Crunch would be the big
squeeze huh what about just the really
big bang to convey this I mean it's it
seems to me like like it's also even if
it were the Big Bang proper it's not
exactly an explosion
well we accept that the signature looks
like if you exploded a grenade for
example or
how about the chrysanthemum fireworks
you know that one mm-hmm
yeah all right well some of them they
they are volume filling right and so the
outer edge well how did it get out that
far and reveal itself at the same time
something that only went half way far
out mm-hmm
right it must have been going twice as
fast huh because they both sort of
explode at the same moment but one is
twice as far away as the other got it
was moving twice as fast that's an
explosion that started this so it's not
completely wrong to think of is it as an
explosion except that when we think of
explosions we think of an explosion in
the pre-existing space right whereas
this is the explosion of space and time
yeah matter and energy itself so it's of
a very different nature but you get a
little bit of the ways of insight into
it if you think about it as an explosion
then you say okay I'm done with that
what more is it to me and then you learn
that it's the expansion of space and
then you move on to deeper ideas yeah I
mean well now the big problem with the
term the big bang is there's trademark
encroachment from the TV show oh yeah so
I don't know if you knew this if you
google the Big Bang Theory the TV show
comes up before the creation of the
universe the universe shops you for me
I'm thinking I am I happy about this I'm
sad about is it good that people are
watching the show it's not scientists I
saw my personal jury is still out on
that I don't know if that's good or bad
it just is well taken up with the show
later all right hey this comes from
Grady Butler the fourth on Facebook he's
got a Roman numeral right Oh does he
yeah he absolutely does so we don't mess
around chicks dig the Roman numerals I'm
told I have no Roman numerals behind my
name
Roman numerals but why not use Arabic
numerals this is not as cool oh yeah or
you could just do like irrational number
numerals yes no to the pie you eat that
uh Neil deGrasse Tyson the pie yeah you
have a son why didn't you do like Neil
deGrasse Tyson E or some yeah yeah no
cuz I don't that's not how I roll it's
not how I roll my name does not manifest
in either of my two children I've never
understood the desire to be like mmm
that's gonna be me property of Sarah
right I just it's not what I do
yeah okay that's good enough for me but
Grady the butler the forth after we've
hated on his name from facebook says hey
dr. Tyson so I've heard a lot about
hiding on his name we were celebrating
his name wondering whether the day will
come where they will use Arabic numerals
all right I'm gonna get to this question
yes for this guy like produces an
offspring okay hey dr. Tyson so I've
heard a lot about cosmic microwave
background radiation what we were just
talking about a lot of physicists
mention it but don't really explain it
so what exactly is it oh yeah that's a
great question so in the early universe
it was really really hot so hot that the
atoms were all ionized so they lose
their electrons so you have this soup of
negatively charged electrons and atoms
that want the electron but can't hold on
to them because the super of energy is
so high it turns out that electrons
wreak havoc on light if you're a light
beam and you try to get through a crowd
of electrons you're not getting through
the electrons see you will scatter you
to and fro like bouncers its bouncers
okay they will push you scatter you
reverse you so there are no free
sightlines through ionized gas there's
no free sightlines through plasma that's
why the Sun is opaque it's just gas yeah
punch your fist through it nothing's
gonna stop you
you'd be vaporized but holding that
complication aside there's no surface
there for you to touch down on it is
glowing plasma and I had a tweet in
reference to that with my end of the Sun
tweet a few you know when was that back
in March and I forgot the whole tweet
something like in five billion years
when the Sun dies it will expand its its
plasma surface will expand and engulf
the orbit of mercury and venus it will
render earth a burnt cinder before it
vaporizes us as we go up in a puff of
smoke into the vacuum of space that was
the tweet
the point is i'm referring to the sun as
plasma the early universe was once all
plasma yeah okay at the temperature that
the Sun was so what happens as we expand
we cool oh now there's not so much
energy to ionize the atoms and all the
electrons find an atom clearing the deck
for light to transmit freely now the
free electrons are no longer there to
bat to and fro the light that wants to
pass through so we now make complete
atoms and light emerges at 3000 degrees
so before there was a plasma state of
matter but no light no this plant sorry
it's a glowing it's glowing just the way
the Sun is its light right oh there's
definitely light could anyone's like if
you just can't see through it you see it
you just don't see through it now watch
it expands and cools electrons join
universe becomes transparent the
universe expands by a factor of a
thousand
and it turns out the amount you expand
is a factor in how much colder it is if
it was a fact if it was 3,000 degrees in
that moment what's it what's one one
thousandth that temperature yeah three
right now the universe is three degrees
how'd you do in your math class okay so
what color light is three degree light
because 3,000 degree light is like
reddish
mber that light has now redshifted hmm -
today that temperature went from 3,000
degrees to 3 degrees because it got
diluted from this expansion what color
is 3 degree light microwaves Wow period
period Mike we are bathed in the
microwave remnants of the formation of
the universe the cooling of the universe
cooling of the universe and now if you
go back in time there won't be
microwaves those would be red and then
right on up to white it's somewhat
revealing it but it was not that hot you
don't serve violate 20,000 degrees
thirty thousand fifty thousand this is
much cooler than that I'm just saying
that we see microwaves because of how
how late we are in the universe yeah
relative to the formation of it and we
call it the Cosmic Microwave Background
which to me sounds like something thanks
somebody with munchies and college is
looking at a cosmic microwave I don't
know if you own when did you graduate
college 2014 24 yesterday I mean 14 1940
pinch your cheek so so in the day when
you have to get up off your ass to
change the TV channel if you put the TV
channel between two channels this is
before of remote controls you don't get
clean signals that are broadcast but
because your this information coming
through an antenna and so what you have
is what we call static right snow yeah
it's on the screen some percent of that
snow is the cosmic microwave background
Wow Oh few percent of it that's you're
measuring it yeah it's everywhere that's
intense and so now that we don't have
TVs we have to change the channel it
doesn't exist you can't do longer works
right
boy that's awesome okay all right we
have time for a very short question
before we go to break this one comes
from Antonio Montoya I don't think that
Sonia Montoya
from facebook says how far must I travel
to see the backside or the reverse view
reverse view of the Big Dipper ooh
interesting
ooh you know I forgot how way how far
away the Big Dipper is I just forgot
just say something confidently but I can
tell you this that the Big Dipper stars
not sort of in a line yes and if they
were in a line you could go to the other
side and then see the Big Dipper in
Reverse but if they're not in a line hmm
you can't do that so I've done this
exercise with all the constellations
none of them look like you have a lot of
free time now me the universe go way
back so you go to the other side of
these constellations they look nothing
like what they would do from this side
yeah as they would from the other side
from above or below yes not just
reversed here's something you do I did
this with classes it's fun get a long
room that can go completely dark give
seven people pen lights or just though
their smartphone will work and orient
them in the shape of the Big Dipper
hmm bring some really close and some
farther away and then have them turn on
their lights and you turn off the main
lights of the room hmm
stand at the end of the room you have no
sense of the distance to them because
you can't see them right just the
brightness just the brightness you also
you can see and you see a perfect Big
Dipper but as you start moving closer to
them Big Dipper is completely gone
that's good
so there's nothing real about these
constellations contrary to what millions
of people in the world think who get
their instructions for their day's life
from the stars so take a quick break our
last break before we get to the third
and final segment of cosmic queries
exciting conclusion Oh Parisian Sarah
we'll be right back
we're back start talking I'm Neil
deGrasse Tyson we are in the potpourri
edition of Startalk Sarah keep it coming
okay all right so the first one comes
from Lynn Hughes and Fall City
Washington she says I get discouraged by
all the anti science rhetoric these days
how do you stay so positive what do
people ask that gives you hope
and what responses are most helpful when
talking to science skeptics mmm is no
such thing as a science skeptic just a
dumbass I'm a gravity skeptic yeah yeah
yeah I'm sceptile sceptile that the Sun
exists no there's no science skeptic
skeptic yes okay so what do I do
where do I stay positive I'm it's
because everyone likes beating
politicians over the head and they
simply bring forth the in an ideal case
and in most case so they bring forth the
wishes of their electorate so if you
beaten the policies on the head you're
really attacking the electorate yeah as
an educator for me the target of my
affection and interest will always be
the people yeah and not the politicians
that they elect so you're getting mad at
a scale instead of getting mad at
exactly repeal the law of gravity
because I gained three pounds last week
how it works so so I think of myself as
an educator in that context and to equip
the general public with the methods and
tools to analyze the moving frontier of
science to process information about
what is the state of science in the
world and what is science and how and
why it works so so and hope springs
eternal my favorite quote of them all is
it and this too shall pass that's pretty
good how did that go over with your kids
been grounded right so yeah I've
the anti-science it'll come back and
bite everyone in the ass
no beetle people ahead I say look if you
don't like science here are the
consequences you will die
sick and hungry and poor but just that
just that that's it innovation since I
say this as iliyan times innovations in
science and technology are the engines
of tomorrow's economy mm-hmm and not
only that it will assure a continued
access to your health your wealth and
your security without which just move
back into the cave and throw rocks
because that's where you belong if you
were always a person in denial I think
the question she asked about how you
stay so positive I know for one thing
you have a great sense of humor about it
like uh some people oh okay no no I
don't have a sense of humor I don't
think of it I think of it just that the
universe is hilarious Oh a hundred
percent and I'm revealing this and I'm
revealing this to whoever will listen so
because I'm not actually telling a joke
right yeah I told a joke no but the
universe is funny so so and I found it
that people learn more when they're
laughing or what at least when they're
smiling is a minimum yeah so why not
celebrate the hilarity of the universe
in ways that have people enable empower
people to learn ever more and go to
comedy shows with comedians because
they'll learn about the universe of
comedians yeah okay so moving on sort of
in the same vein psy hunter on Instagram
asks why do flat earthers still exist
question mark exclamation point
exclamation point yeah so flat earthers
i've analyzed this problem yes and I've
concluded the existence of flat earthers
mm-hmm is the manifestation the
simultaneous manifestation of two facts
mm-hmm one we live in a country in the
United States that protects free speech
- we live in a country the failed
educational system
combine those to mind those two you have
flattered to the the flat earth our
hypothesis for the existence of flat
earthers I kind of love that applying
science um they exist in an unstable
state you should be stable I'm not so so
I say go ahead and think the earth is
flat I'm not gonna stop you it's a free
country we at least we tell ourselves
that it's a free country so it but you
should not look for a job to head NASA
right there certain certain job
categories you shouldn't stay clear out
and it's you know if not only for those
there's folks who are like afraid of the
numbers 13 oh yeah right there are
elevators that go don't go to the 13th
floor more than half of elevators have
no 13th floor I'd I studied this oh my
god along Broadway in Manhattan you can
go to every building but broader has
plenty of tall buildings its statistic
is about half so dude is that floor
empty or is it just the foil for some
buildings that goes from the 12th floor
to the 14th floor yeah for some
buildings for other buildings they put
all the mechanicals on that floor oh my
gosh but still a floor yeah still floor
but they they hide it yeah so a
free-speech go right ahead
you look exhausted by this time it's I'm
not gonna fight you if you want to think
about it
go ahead you know you're just good you
know the there plenty of jobs for you if
you're superstitious about the number 13
or you want the plenty jobs for you
mm-hmm go right ahead but and let's hope
the people who are hiring also know how
that should go down so if they don't
where that's the end beginning of the
end of the event inform democracy I
think that there's a lot to why people
think the earth is flat because it seems
to be this comforting like conspiracy
theory that like scientists are trying
to cover-up knowledge that we don't know
yet
it's just odd that anyone would think
scientists would be leaders in covering
up knowledge that we somehow would be
conspiring mm-hmm that somehow we're all
conspiring to make the world look like
it's getting hotter right you might say
well why what's little advantage what
exactly could possibly motivate us yeah
as a diverse community of scientists and
I don't know either so I'm too tired I'm
too old I can't chase people I wish that
these mics were droppable unfortunately
they're in a steady state condition okay
let's see here's a very interesting one
I've never considered before mr. Nate
cap on Instagram ass could there be a
universe inside a black hole yes oh wow
next question
lightning round okay so the equations of
space-time mm-hmm as you follow them
across the event horizon toward the
singularity allow an entire new universe
to open up in front of it Wow so as you
fall into a black hole your time ticks
slower and slower and anti-aging
yes well yes yes yeah I'm about the
exfoliator so you do this and time
changes for you so adds time change of
you you will see the entire future
history of the universe unfold before
your very eyes Wow as the new space-time
opens in front of you it's very hard to
remain funny and have jokes when you
just constantly blow my mind Neil what
so are you tempted then to like go into
a black hole because you could see if I
had to die yeah you'd go oh yeah better
get hit by bus or die in a cancer or
something oh yeah I'll die falling into
a black hole yeah right
spaghettification yeah so so they're
very much they're very well could be
universes inside black holes yes whole
universes right all right okay so like
moving on to our next question
oh I like this one Roger Roger BA on
Facebook
does e equals mc-squared does that
equation work with dark matter and dark
energy as far as we know we have no
reason to think it wouldn't so whatever
it is that's causing the dark energy if
it one day shows itself to have mass
it's going to join the rest of all of
the the mass out there and as a as a
constituent if now dark energy we don't
know what that is if it has mass so we
don't know mm-hmm so but yeah equals MC
squared is fundamental in fact it's true
for everything everything huh I'll give
you an example if you take a spring and
dissolve it in acid okay and then
measure the temperature of the acid
you'll get some value if you take a
spring compress it first pumping energy
into it and put that in the acid and
dissolve the acid mm-hmm the temperature
of that asset is higher than the
temperature of the answer that you
dissolve the unsprung spring okay so it
takes the energy right so you so so
equals MC squared that e and that M work
no matter what Wow it is completely
fundamental to all phenomena in the
universe huh yeah it's I mean it's
interesting I I tend to view dark matter
and dark energy is sort of like normal
matter and energy but with like an evil
goatee yeah
it's when cousin and then I imagine a
equals MC squared was evil I don't know
maybe early illustrations to the devil
maybe ahead goatee potentially I don't
know somehow it got the the branding of
the goatee went downhill it was some guy
maybe who started it the mustache I feel
like it's making a comeback you're in
luck
you have a mustache soul patch situation
I hope n is that kind of mustache I've
never shaved the upper half of my
mustache in my life upper to grow yeah
oh yeah it kinda it's kind of hovering
around the lake yeah that's a lower half
of the upper lip so I always figured
that equals MC squared would have some
sort of like inverse relationship with
dark matter dark energy just if it's
matter at all or energy at all it can
fit into that equation and convert to
the other Wow
okay no matter what oh yeah it's just
it's dark okay all right let's see my
next question and I think probably our
final question for time for one more
question yes okay so did the lightning
round yeah we didn't do a lightning
round
okay so our last one comes from King
Jameis on Instagram what are your
thoughts Inge yeah apparently it's a
king so thank you your honor
your royal your highness for reaching
out to us on Instagram what
probably Instagram I'm guessing or his
mom's basement um all right so King Jay
Mathias on Instagram asked what are your
thoughts on China planning to get rid of
all the space junk with lasers ooh about
this yeah so so space junk is bad yeah I
think we haven't been visited by aliens
cuz I saw the stationary said forget
that y'all just methane right right
put my ship at risk because you're
garbage yeah and so a couple of things
you can do with lasers
you can vaporize the target you can
accelerate it out of out of orbit right
put on a different planet yeah you can
do multiple things but I will say that
that's a big cleanup job because it's
not like a spilled thing on the floor
yeah in your kitchen it's scattered all
over the solar system and then you hope
it doesn't cover to come out to kill you
again ideally we would vacuum it all up
and send it into the Sun where it will
vaporize yeah bury it or something that
somehow feels like a cop-out it somehow
feels like you know we should just be
having less junk out should have a
handle our own junk yeah don't pass the
buck to the Sun we have cosmic sweeping
under the rugs and one of the most
famous books ever written on gravity
it's called gravity gravitation there's
a they talked about a black hole and how
you could use it to cycle grab cycle
garbage weight
again we see a black hole this like
giant cosmic phenomena beautiful place
to put our garbage right the case first
gets too filled up with garbage non
biodegradable garbage just toss it into
the black hole so Sierra we got to call
it I think we do thank you fit your
first time I survived it I'm still large
it was okay for me take it I'll take it
yeah we needed ups upside potential
there you have been watching and
possibly more likely listening to
Startalk
it's the cosmic queries poopourri
edition Sara thanks for being on the
show I am Neil deGrasse Tyson your
personal astrophysicist and as always I
bid you to keep looking up
you